first of all guys congratulations on a
second season
and like an amazing second season i have
to i have to add like
what's cool about this show is
simultaneously you get to turn
like your brain off but then also you
have to have like
almost like a phd to understand who
these characters are
where they're coming from and where
they're going as as
the actors do you guys have like um
white boards with interconnected lines
about like
tips and like the history and all that
stuff because
i imagine it can get a bit confusing
oh yeah i mean not necessarily like an
actual
dry erase board with like you know like
we're solving some sort of murder
mystery
with the red string but you know there's
definitely moments where
you know because you know i the way that
i work is
we get the scripts you know i read the
whole episode once
maybe twice but usually once and then i
kind of have to hone in
on on like the allison scenes and kind
of the work that i have to do there
and so um you know i i like forget
things that happen to other people
because there's so many stories and so
many different
you know different journeys that are
happening all at once so it definitely
can get
um can get a little confusing in moments
especially in scenes where we all come
together and i'm just like wait
where were you and where are you coming
from but then i also think that's the
joy of watching it too because i
i have forgotten so much it's like i
really so much of watching it is like
through
fresh eyes because it's like yes i read
it and yes you know i was there
shooting a lot but i'm you know i'm only
in the scene that i'm in and i'm not
upset when
you know when everybody else is shooting
so it's i kind of enjoy the aspect that
there's
so much chaos and so many stories and so
many things happening because it kind of
provides for a really great viewing
experience
how much of a gap of time was there
between when you finished filming the
first season and started filming the
second
it was about a year wasn't it yeah it
was i think it was like may
we finished in uh like july
of 18 and then i think we started in
like may
june yeah of so what was it like for you
guys getting
all getting back together like what was
the first scene do you guys remember
shooting for season two uh the first one
we all did together was actually the
uh the big opening sequence uh when
uh we see all the nuclear bombs and
stuff going on that's uh
that was the first time we were all
actually together on set
um which was great it was really it was
really fun like
that's the best thing about the show you
know is the is the the time where
we're all on set together it's the time
we have the biggest laughs you know so
yeah it was good uh ellen we really get
to see
uh vanya's character uh evolve and
change and
you have the unique um
i don't want to give away but your
storyline here is unique among all of
your
siblings what was it like for you
getting to play this different side of
her
um it was it was so nice i uh
yeah you know vania at the beginning of
this new season is
is quite different than the last season
and in many ways she felt like
um you know establishing a bit of a new
character in a way because
the end of the first season we see her
release
a lot of energy a lot of repressed
emotions and anger and trauma
it doesn't benefit the world because she
does blow up the moon
but we find her in the beginning of the
second season and she's
you know she's lighter she's happier she
uh she's more open she can connect to
her emotions
she can connect to you know other people
she falls in love for the first time
um and uh so as an actor
you know it was about sort of you know
figuring out how she was gonna
um yeah exist and the way she moves the
way she talks you know the way she
relates to people
um and then going on her journey
throughout the season was uh
was incredibly um uh enjoyable and
fulfilling as an actor
yeah now among all the plot twists and
turns and the some of the superheroics
there's also a very very relevant uh
storyline in this like you're landing in
the early 60s
it's civil rights um and we're here
today in 2020
reflecting on so many of the same things
what do you hope and i don't know if you
thought about that while you were
filming but now looking back on it what
do you hope the audience takes
from the story lines in your show as
they reflect on the present day
uh you know i think um you know as a
black woman
kind of having to relive the experiences
and the trauma and the struggle of the
civil rights movement i think i
i already felt so many parallels and
and it already it it it resonated with
me in a very
real current um way but i think you know
there's something very surreal about the
show coming out now in the wake of
george floyd and in the middle of this
black lives matter movement and i think
um
i think the biggest takeaway is that i
think the show is shining a bright light
on the fact that you know there is no
difference between
a sit-in like a sit-in riot
and and and the riots that had like
the protests that escalated to violent
acts
by agitators um you know during the
protests and the marches for george
floyd and and so many other
other marches um for the black lives
matter movement i think it's
it's that fight is is ongoing that fight
is is persistent and and i think we are
dealing with and trying to to unearth
some really deep roots of systemic
racism in this country and
prejudice and um for for marginalized
people
in the lgbtq community it is it is such
a big fight for justice and equality
and i think um you know i think sure the
civil rights feels like
well we didn't live through it but you
know our our grandparents did and and
our parents you know were children and i
think it's
ruby bridges was the first black girl to
integrate an all-white school and she
just turned 65.
you know what i mean so i think it's it
is it feels like it's in the past
but it's it's not it's it's the same
fight and it is generational
and it has been generational for 400
years yeah
yeah well thank you so much for your
time you guys
um and thank you for the season i'm
looking forward to the third season that
cliffhanger is uh
the cliffhanger is crazy again i can't i
wish i could talk about but i can't
yeah so thank you so much and enjoy your
day guys
you